what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and there are a ton of
new projects coming to the mcu both
movies and disney plush shows of course
we have everything that disney has
already announced but we also have
movies and shows coming that they
haven't officially announced yet but
have been announced by some major trade
companies like deadline and variety and
i've been getting a ton of requests from
you all on twitter on instagram in the
comments of youtube to do an updated
video on the future of marvel studios
and what's interesting is i've actually
been hearing some concern for the future
of the mcu based on some projects that
have already come out and some future
projects coming out and people seem
primarily concerned with the lack of
connectivity that the mcu has right now
but i think this video could put you
back at ease as we talk about all of the
really really important projects coming
up in the mcu and how they're all
actually going to connect together so
let's dive into it and of course if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
marvel videos so to start off i'm just
gonna say that we're not really going to
be talking about sony's marvel verse in
this video they do have a lot coming on
their end but unless it's a spider-man
movie starring tom holland none of it's
really going to cross over but quick
sidenote it does sound like sony is
planning on starting up their new
spider-man films starring tom holland
zendaya and jacob battle on pretty soon
so that's really exciting and they do
have other things like madame webb venom
3 el muerto a spider woman movie and
more coming up but of course none of
that connects to the mcu as far as the
connectivity of the mcu goes right now
there's one major thing that you need to
understand because it's very different
than the past in previous years marvel
studios would release about two to three
movies a year and that was it that was
all we would get that's what the
infiniti saga was a few movies a year
all kind of having easter eggs to the
other movies or references at least and
then every few years the avengers would
get together and then at the end we had
avengers end game where pretty much the
whole universe got together but now you
have to understand that we have disney
plus but we have disney plus on top of
now four movies a year from marvel
studios and disney plus seems to be
releasing four to five new series a year
so this is a lot of new content and all
of this content is not going to connect
right away and that's kind of the good
thing about disney plus is that there's
so much content out there they can
actually focus on individual stories but
rest assured everything does connect
because marvel studios president kevin
feige did say with the exception of like
marvel zombies and marvel's what if you
will have to watch these disney plus
shows to kind of know what is happening
in the mcu one division was a perfect
example of that if you didn't watch one
division well then doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness was not nearly
as good for you than it was for
everybody who watched it but then you
have shows like moon knight which
seemingly don't really mention anything
about the mcu however it still did
connect they even mentioned magipore in
the show and while that was only a
little bit of a connection it still did
connect but i wouldn't expect the big
connections and big team ups to come
from disney plus because that's what the
movies are for disney plus is going to
focus on individual stories and they're
kind of just going to keep that focus
one division focused on one division
loki focused on loki and all of the loki
variants moon knight was about moon
knight and mark specter and stephen
grant and then eventually jake lockley
but you get where i'm going with this
the movies however are where things are
going to go down but on top of that they
are going to have specific disney plus
shows that address a lot of things
happening in the mcu secret invasion is
a perfect example and we'll talk about
that in a bit but one thing i need you
to keep in mind is that this is a new
saga and we are now in the building
phase once more when the mcu originally
started it had to build they built up to
the avengers and while yes there was
some connectivity there it's not like
thor himself was name-dropping captain
america and iron man point being they
had to build then once they had the
first avengers film that's where
everything seemed to be really really
connected well that's kind of where we
are right now and honestly things are
about to get really really exciting i've
seen the first two episodes of miss
marvel and i can personally tell you
that there are so many easter eggs and
miss marvel and so much connectivity to
the mcu so that feeling of things not
being connected is about to go away big
time especially if you look at some key
projects coming up let's go through them
and we're going to start with like i
said miss marvel and she hulk now in
miss marvel and they showed this in the
trailer so it's not a spoiler they go to
avengers con so as you can imagine there
is a lot of easter eggs there and a lot
of connectivity so that's really cool
then in she-hulk we are going to see
wong which has been confirmed we've
already seen abomination and rumor has
it right now that we're going to see
daredevil which is really really awesome
and very expected because daredevil is
getting his own disney plus series plus
he's going to be appearing in the echo
series and in the echo series we're
going to be getting like i mentioned
daredevil but also kingpin so already
with those shows right there that's a
lot of connectivity happening and that's
just disney plus shows now of course
miss marvel she's going to go on to join
captain marvel in the marvels and also
the marvels is going to connect to the
secret invasion disney plus show and the
marvels and secret invasion are going to
be very very big as far as impact on the
mcu but before we get to those we
actually have other projects that are
going to be really impactful as well
doctor strange 2 was already extremely
impactful but then we have wakanda
forever coming up now wakanda forever is
going to introduce namor and most likely
atlantis since that's where he comes
from now this could be the start of the
introduction of mutants in the mcu
depending on how they depict namor but
the implications of a war between namor
and wakanda are pretty big plus not to
mention we need a new black panther not
a new t'challa but a new black panther
and we should figure out who that is in
wakanda forever and then of course we
have possibly the biggest heavy hitter
in the mcu coming up and that is ant-man
and the wasp quantum mania where they
will introduce kang the conqueror who
along with some variants of himself will
be one of the main big bads of this next
phase also thor love and thunder is the
next movie that is going to come out and
while i do believe that thor is mostly
going to focus on thor and the entire
cast around it i think introducing the
different gods and having statues of the
cosmic entities in the trailer mean that
this movie is going to have somewhat of
a big impact on the mcu different gods
were introduced in moon knight as well
and now we're going to hear gore the god
butcher's story and we'll probably run
into some other gods that we haven't
seen before in the mcu so thor love and
thunder is going to be really important
and impactful as well and then of course
we have the fantastic four coming up and
that sort of speaks for itself i think
everybody is extremely excited for this
movie and i think it's going to be a
game changer for the mcu i really think
it's going to completely shift it we're
about to have an insanely awesome team
in the mcu and the world's smartest man
and the cool thing about the fantastic
four is they can do battle on earth but
they can also be a cosmic team as well
which brings us to the cosmic side of
the mcu which is the marvels which i
already talked about but don't forget
about guardians of the galaxy vol 3 and
nova nova is confirmed to be coming to
the mcu and it looks like since this is
going to be the last guardians of the
galaxy film from james gunn and most of
the cast it looks like the guardians are
going to be set up as an official team
an official team of protecting the
galaxy where characters can actually be
interchanged so after guardians 3 we're
not going to have the original team but
hopefully some characters will stay like
star-lord and hopefully they get some
new ones like nova and adam warlock and
other really awesome characters then of
course we have loki season 2 coming in
this is where things are going to get
really really interesting kevin feige
confirmed that the only way the events
of spider-man know a home could play out
in the events of doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness and anything else
multiverse that is up and coming these
events were only allowed to happen
because of what happened in loki season
1. if loki and sylvie hadn't have killed
he who remains the tva would have
stepped in and stopped all of this from
happening so loki season 2 is going to
be extremely important not only for the
sacred timeline and the multiverse but
also for another introduction of kang
the conqueror and then of course we have
movies like captain america 4 coming up
and this could be the start of the new
avengers team which obviously would have
a lot of connections and last but
certainly not least we have blade coming
up and this is going to be the start of
kind of our monster side of the mcu well
really moon night was the start of it
but blade is going to take this even
further and hopefully be the start of
the introduction of the midnight suns
team and i am personally really really
excited for that to finally happen in
the mcu so as you can see here there's a
lot of really really exciting stuff
coming up for the mcu and if you've been
worried about the connectivity i hope
this video has helped you at least a
little bit but let me know what you
think about the future of the mcu in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the future marvel
videos for live updates you can follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you